hoje por aquela perna
atrás entraram aqueles
milhares de sonhos alguns mais simples
alguns mais banais alguns que quase
parecem uma meta de vida que ele tem um
carro uma casa própria é um filho
outros no entanto parecem pouco mais
absurdo talvez como querer ser um
astronauta inclusive nada contra as
tendências e tampouco na hora de crescer
continuando eu imagino que agora
enquanto falamos sobre sonhos talvez
comecem a pensar sobre uma outra coisa
dentro da cabeça o que contar com a
ajuda de vocês agora pra que vocês
mentaliza 100 coisas que vocês desejam e
quando falar se chega você se
levantassem a mão pra mim para sinalizar
que vocês se lembrarão de algo então vou
dar alguns segundos chega a levantar pra
mim então por favor que lembrou de um
outro sonho é levantar sem vergonha não
tem julgamento
lendo uma duas todo mundo que lindo que
não levantou brigar de igual é que
algumas pessoas ficaram meu problema é
que eu vou fingir que não vi bom quando
comecei a pensar sobre o que eu ia falar
aqui pra vocês eu me dei conta que na
verdade eu sou um grande jogador mas tão
grande que quase concordado
e aí o que a gente deve saber
claro que agora gustavo já anunciou mas
eu fui meio que na unisinos ea
capacidade de sonhar que me permitiu
gradual
é o flamengo com uma bolsa de estudos no
ensino não é o que me permitiu conhecer
professoras fantásticos colegas
maravilhosos que eu carrego comigo até
hoje e também um concurso de design
ainda mais fantástico eu ia falar outra
palavra para dar mais ênfase só que não
possa e aí depois que me formei eu
acabei mudando para belo horizonte
atrás de um coração apaixonado por uma
menina linda que deve estar em algum
lugar aqui eu espero
foi uma das coisas mais loucas que eu
fiz na minha vida porque eu tinha 600
reais no bolso é eu não tinha lugar para
ficar
eu não sabia em que eu ia trabalhar
direito porque não tinha emprego e bom
foi uma loucura e claro que quando eu
peguei essa loucura foi conversar com os
meus amigos sobre isso
como bons amigos que estão sempre do
lado do japão em qualquer coisa que
quero fazer
eles me falaram cara só pode tá louco
mas fazer sentido
no entanto quando foi falar com a minha
mãe eu falei pra ela mãe eu tô indo e
ela disse vai tenta se não der certo
volta e eu fui eu fui aquela certeza me
um jovem de que se não desse certo eu
tinha um porto seguro para voltar e bom
ator já faz quase seis anos
não que tenha dado certo mas eu continuo
tentando e aí lá em belo horizonte
falando sério agora eu comecei a
descobrir algum sentido sobre algumas
palavras que a gente fala que sabe às
vezes não sabe tanto eu comecei a ter
que me dá conta que eu tinha que dar
adeus por alguns familiares que não
voltaria a ver
comecei a me dar conta que eu rebatia
amigos que também mudar e não encontra
mais e pessoas que simplesmente perdeu o
contato mas ainda mais forte do que isso
eu acabei descobrindo que é o sentido da
palavra saudade
qual o sentido da palavra a deus ea pior
de todas que é uma merda a palavra
esquecimento se esquecido é uma merda
porque você não quer que as pessoas
esqueçam e tudo que vocês passaram
juntos
mas você também acaba esquecendo isso
foi um processo muito delicado muito
difícil no início só que com esse
processo todo que me fez crescer rápido
que me fez enfrentar as coisas de uma
outra maneira suportar todas as porradas
que a gente tomou no início
e aí tem forças pra fazer uma
transformação
bom depois de um tempo lá em belo
horizonte
é a gente descobre que você tem que se
adaptar
você não tem tempo bom nos filmes para
sofrer que sofreu na vida real não é tão
legal você não tem tempo mimi você não
tem tempo pra ficar de choramingo e aí
depois de fazer quase tudo um pouco e
quando falo quase tudo um pouco
mente limpa por favor eu acabei entrando
no mundo das estátuas e minha vida se
transformou nesta etapa é conhecido das
melhores
sonhos que eu carrego comigo hoje que o
ricardo nunca 100 mil sócios a pique
esconde mas dela vou falar mais além de
bom nessa etapa que a gente se conheceu
a gente teve uma experiência fantástica
porque a gente começou a conhecer é e
investidores
a gente teve contato com gente grande no
mercado e além disso a gente teve
contato com uma porrada de termo técnico
que eu não sabia o que significava mas
balançava a cabeça e sorrindo tem gente
que não sabe se saber se alguém estava
me xingando não
aí eu peguei essa experiência toda e
falei eu consigo eu também vou montar
uma idéia é óbvio porque a gente quase
vive num país é que obriga empreender e
como todo mundo que aprendi na prática
como empreender com a pouca experiência
que tem
o que acontece eu errei errei feio é
relevante
mais ou menos o que aconteceu foi aquilo
que a gente faz quando a gente é
funcionário a gente assim é fácil né no
quinto olha o teu chefe disse
como é que ele pode fazer isso esse cara
é muito burro quando foi chefe eu nunca
vou fazer isso aí vira chefe pimba as
duas certezas desaparecem as obviedades
somem e do caminho não vale nem bolo das
incertezas uma loucura é bom
a primeira ideia surgiu e ela é bem
simples de ser explicado é era uma loja
virtual onde venderia almofadas
customizadas as pessoas mandaram arte
para a gente manter essa arte pagar a
outros processos pessoas lendo o nome da
empresa chegaram a sentar aqui muito
fofa né eu sei e bom
depois de três meses de empresa a gente
começou a fazer alguns cálculos
mirabolantes que talvez só gustavo reis
que é professor de matemática
palestrante critério conseguiria aí a
gente começou a ver que os números não
estavam tão bem e aí começa a bater o
desespero passado e radu contra os meus
agentes descobriram que a gente
precisava fechar o agente deixou a
empresa com três meses fechou tudo e
agora aí um dia eu tenho uma livraria
com luca assim aquele meu sócio que
tinha dito antes também estava nessa
idéia é a gente avisou um livro chamado
mil e uma coisas para se fazer antes de
morrer
lucas ele olhou pra mim e pra mim pra
ele e eu falei cara isso pode virar um
aplicativo ele disse pode e viu depois
de um tempo eu conheci a roberta e pedro
que são nossos sócios atingido e junto a
gente passou por uma transformação muito
grande porque a gente acaba de passar
por esses momentos que a gente não
imaginava que a gente passaria a gente
foi investido
a gente fechou parcerias com várias
empresas do cenário nacional e global se
a gente teve um banho de usuários por um
bom momento
a gente ganhou o concurso da mão deles e
ultimamente agora não mais recentemente
passou nesta tática mas a grande coisa
veio quando a gente foi selecionado como
um dos melhores aplicativos da apple
store brasileira em 2014
isso é muito grande certo e aí você está
olhando agora aqui na frente falando
disso estou pensando caramba esse é o
novo mark zuckerberg brasileiro
esse cara tá rico quero ser amigo dele e
tudo o que eu posso falar pra vocês
quanto a isso é não
eu não sou novo mark zuckerberg
brasileiro eu não estou rico mas a gente
ainda pode ser amigo beleza
bom eu comecei a perceber também depois
desse processo de transformação com
startup que quando a gente faz alguma
coisa que foge do padrão as pessoas
buscam elas têm tilt cerebral é bem
linguagem de nerd porque né
e aí eu comecei a ver que elas chegavam
para me perguntava rafa como é que tu
ganha dinheiro mas que tem empresa faz
cara como como é que funciona e alguns
me perguntava sempre tem mais que dista
trabalho um computador sabe formatar o
windows e tinha aquele outro que ia
chegar nós é claro que a garota de
programa e que legal só que não é muito
bom é bom o que a gente foi percebido
também é que ao longo do tempo
o conceito de startup foi se perdendo
porque a gente começou a se acostumar
com aquele boom de informação 10 dicas
de quem largou tudo para seguir seu
sonho ea gente pensa nossa eu também vou
eu vou largar seu emprego chato e vou
fazer o que eu quiser eu tenho uma ideia
que também genial ela vai ser milionária
eu vou ficar rico nesse mercado atrás
dele movimentou em 2012
bilhões de reais é muita grana em 2012 e
aí claro que você está olhando agora
começa a pensar nossa também enterrou
executar ela agora será equipar super
inspirado vou fazer tudo só que na
verdade a ideia só cirurgia do bolo
tem muita coisa rolando por trás e aí
que o negócio tomar corpo na verdade eu
diria que a grande diferença é que você
tem que aceitar o risco eu aceitei o
risco o risco e mantém vivo ele me faz
acordar todo dia com vontade de atrás
com gana de ter que fazer algo diferente
porque o final do mês não está garantido
e sem residência se essa fosse a vontade
de continuar
é muito complicado trabalhar no meio
você tem que ter certeza de que falhar
não é um problema
na verdade falar é um processo natural
porque ele vai te fazer crescer a vida
vai te derrubar
ela vai tentar dar porrada mas você tem
que existir
e aí que a transformação vai acontecer
mas antes de tudo isso você tem que
saber os valores que você está propondo
você tem que saber que os seus sonhos
tem que ter prioridade
senão a coisa se perde ea trajetória não
é tão divertido fazer uma pausa rápida
uma história há oito anos atrás
a minha mãe que é uma mulher é
excepcionalmente maravilhosa e eu fico
feliz ela é a minha mãe não de vocês
ela teve a ideia genial de receber a
camisa da alemanha
e aí é a primeira cabeça e fala pra casa
transformou nossa vida a gente não
imaginar e naquele momento e ela tinha
um namorado que o andrés não alemão
ele foi visitar ela aí eles acabaram ela
foi embora depois ele vem com uma outra
namorada ea gente foi eu e meu namorado
para o casamento deles lá na alemanha e
um bom ano passado no final do ano ele
falou rafa e pode ir para belo horizonte
ficar uns dias de férias eu falei não
vem cá e ele acabou conhecendo o que eu
fazia e eu acabei conhecendo que ele
fazia era a mesma coisa
a gente fazia websites nem toda a gente
tinha um estúdio digital né cape cod que
eu falei lá atrás ea gente acabou
falando assim
caramba vamos trabalhar juntos e eu
falei desde que a gente desenvolve para
vocês
a coisa começou a tomar corpo foi dando
certo ele um dia chegou para mim e falou
rafa vamos fazer maior
vamos fundir vamos fazer uma empresa só
aqui e lá a mãe nem falei 'vamos óbvio
porque estou falando não estou falando
que eu sou fascinado com a terra da
cerveja de salsicha eu tô falando isso
também estou na verdade mas estou
falando isso porque aí tem que se abrir
essas oportunidades que às vezes
aparecem agarrar elas assim é o seu
indie pitt da vida que acontece todos os
dias gente das oportunidades passando e
às vezes a gente acaba esquecendo disso
e vive a vida dos outros porque tivemos
15 cêntimos história recente livro é de
filme identifica nossa que história
legal mas a gente fica lá vivendo aquele
cotidiano
a gente vive o dia a dia a gente pode
fazer mais uma outra história que queria
contar pra vocês é de um ex colega meu
falou comigo ele veio de uma cidade de 2
mil habitantes
ele nunca tinha falado em outro idioma
só português e lançou - e ele também
nunca tinha mexido computador mas o pior
é que ele tinha uma renda mensal de
r$100 para cinco pessoas
sério esse cara ele obviamente é um
exemplo de vida pra mim pra muita gente
hoje é quase um semideus em ancorar que
a cidade dele e ele aprendeu inglês em
dois anos e deve mexer com três de hoje
é melhor que muito engenheiro da nasa
mas o mais legal é que mesmo assim ele
não perdeu as origens e ele continua
humilde honesto e sonhando mais longe
ele continua olhando pra frente fico um
pouco triste na verdade de ver muita
gente falando que acha legal arriscar
mas não há risco embora quisesse
é aquela história que ele estava falando
aqui sobre não tentar viver a vida dos
outros
essa vida que a gente tem é única e além
disso é muito limitada de tempo mas ela
é ilimitada dos sonhos se lembra que no
início eu falei para vocês que você
queria contar com ajuda para que
levantasse mostrar seus sonhos
na verdade eu também tenho muitos sonhos
mas um deles estão realizando aqui de
olhos bem abertos
obrigado foi um prazer e uma honra até
mais